il aura suffit d'un ancart dans le
journal Le Canard Enchaîné quelques
lignes faisant un lien entre son projet
d'incubateur de start-up à Rony le
DaVinci Labs et l'éviction de la préfète
désormais sous les projecteurs Xavier
Aubry estime avoir été campeur victime
d'une campagne malhonnête Aurélie Renaud
la rencontre chez lui
il y a 3 ans et demi Xavier Aubry et son
épouse rachète le château de La Vallière
ils investissent 15 millions d'euros et
le château devient un hôtel de luxe de
20 chambres le projet numéro 2 de Xavier
Aubry se situe sur une zone aujourd'hui
agricole à 500 mètres du château
d'agricole récemment reboisée et son nom
le DaVinci Labs un incubateur pour les
startups et les chercheurs le bâtiment
de 4000 m² serait dédié entre autres au
biotechnologies un projet éclaboussé par
la polémique selon le Canard Enchaîné la
préfète d'Indre-et-Loire aurait été
limogé pour avoir retoqué le dossier
depuis l'homme d'affaires également
vétérinaire se dit victime de fausses
accusations quand on est vétérinaire
défenseurs de l'environnement qu'on a
fait 20 ans de science dédiées à la
protection de l'environnement et qu'on
se voit accusé de saccager
l'environnement c'est difficile à avaler
mais après il y a les attaques
personnelles
les les menaces les gens qui n'ont qui
n'ont pas compris la polémique ou qui
qui ont qui ont malheureusement cru les
raccourcis
mensongers qui en ont été faits et qui
sont très remontés contre l'élection de
la préfète mais qui donc englobe cette
éviction ce projet
alors que il y a pas de raison de
l'associer à cette problématique alors
le DaVinci Labs est-il à l'arrêt
non immensera vertueux produira de
l'énergie renouvelable et sera invisible
depuis la départementale et le château
Xavier Aubry y investira 15 millions
d'euros sur ces fonds propres il est
aujourd'hui toujours soutenu par le
maire de Rosny et le président de la
communauté de communes je pense que
c'est un contre-feu pour masquer des
choses qui ont conduit à son éviction
qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce projet
alors peut-être aussi elle a été mal
entourée parce que il est possible que
des gens autour d'elle et voulu
exploiter la situation à des fins
purement politiques enfin suite à des
menaces Xavier Aubry a sollicité la
gendarmerie pour assurer la protection
de sa propriété